[Music]
you're waiting for me to get down on my
knees and beg for your forgiveness you
can forget it it's not gonna happen
big I might throw you a play fans of
American Horror Story might just throw
Ryan Murphy a parade he's bringing back
to fan favorite themes for season 8 I
just think he's always at the forefront
of coolness premiering September 12th on
FX
AHS apocalypse will be a crossover of
Murder House and coven something even
star Sarah Paulsen has long been looking
forward to I would like to visit
Cordelia again because you know she
didn't really come into her own until
the last last few episodes and I would
love to see what would happen to someone
who was basically so pure and decent in
kind
when she became the most powerful of
them all and what what would that do and
would she be corrupted and you know she
is her mother's daughter and her mother
was a corruptible creature so I'm sort
of interested to see that would be
interesting to me after taking on the
big screen in oceans 8 and the
anticipated adaptation of the Goldfinch
opposite Nicole Kidman Sarah returns to
her AHS roots in a leading role this
season Evan Peters and Kathy Bates also
received top billing while returning
players Cheyenne Jackson Adina Porter
Billy Eichner and Lesley Grossman will
also appear but it's the addition of
living legend Joan Collins that really
has fans buzzing we were at the Vanity
Fair Oscar party and we turned around
and I was like oh my god they're stone
Collins and he grabbed me by the hand
and off we went and that that deal was
made on that floor this always surprised
me like that Connie Britton and Dylan
McDermott starred in the series first
installment and recently told et they'd
be more than happy to move back into the
Murder House that would be so fun I
don't know anything about that but I'm
in yes what do you think that she's up
to she's dead she's a ghost
I think she's having a great time
anytime the work of Brian Murphy he's
the Andy Warhol of our time I love him
and murder house was was incredible
so yeah I'm down
[Music]